On September 25, 1926, the Ford Motor Company
instituted a five-day, 40-hour work week for
its factory employees.
While Ford wasn’t the first to do this,
they were arguably one of the most influential.
This action, at least initially, did not win
Ford many friends among his fellow business
owners, some of whom believed giving the working
man any time off just encouraged them to indulge
in drink even more than they already did.
(To be fair, that was a real problem around
this era.
It was not from nothing that excessive drink
was blamed for many of society’s woes at
the time, ultimately inspiring Prohibition,
which even a very large percentage of said
drinkers supported in the beginning.
But, of course, if you had to work 14-16 hour
days, 6 days per week from your very early
teen years on- for reference in 1890 the average
work week in the United States for a blue-collar
factory worker was 90-100 hours- you might
be driven to drink excessively too.
;-))
Beyond this, many competing employers were
still miffed at Ford for raising his (male)
workers’ salaries up to five dollars per
day (about $116 today) back in 1914, double
the former going rate, and around the same
time cutting the typical work week down to
48 hours at his factories.
(Women had to wait until 1916 to command the
same wage.)
But since Ford was one the world’s largest
manufacturers, most in the industry were compelled
for various reasons to follow their example,
like it or not.
Ford stated in his company’s newsletter,
Just as the eight-hour day opened our way
to prosperity in America, so the five-day
work week will open our way to still greater
prosperity … It is high time to rid ourselves
of the notion that leisure for workmen is
either lost time or a class privilege.
Of course, Ford wasn’t just doing this out
of the goodness of his heart.
He understood that a five-day work week with
“eight hours labour, eight hours recreation,
eight hours rest” would encourage working
people to vacation on weekends, shop on Saturdays,
and have ample free time to fill during their
daily 8 hour recreation time.
(See: Why a Typical Work Day is Eight Hours
Long) People with more leisure time required
more clothing, ate a greater variety of food
and, of course, were far more likely to be
in the market to buy an automobile to travel
around in.
Workers who were paid more also were more
likely to be able to afford such an automobile.
Beyond benefiting sales as other companies
followed suit, he had also observed that happy
workers (both in their home and work life)
meant better and more efficient workers.
Now, Ford expected his workers to produce
in those shorter working hours, but with the
higher pay and weekends off, there were very
few complaints from any of his employees.
They were happy to put the pedal to the metal
Monday through Friday for their excellent
salary and five-day, 40 hour work week.
As Ford had thought, after instituting these
changes, productivity skyrocketed, meaning
he was getting more results from significantly
fewer work hours and company loyalty and pride
among Ford employees was equally boosted.
Beyond low-skilled laborers banging down the
doors to get work at Ford, he also now had
the luxury of having the top talent in each
of the high-skilled fields he needed workers
for applying in droves.
Needless to say, manufacturers all over the
world would soon follow Ford’s example,
which played right into his hands.
Edsel Ford, Henry’s son and then company
president, was quoted in March of 1922 in
the New York Times as saying of all this,
“Every man needs more than one day a week
for rest and recreation….The Ford Company
always has sought to promote [an] ideal home
life for its employees.
We believe that in order to live properly
every man should have more time to spend with
his family.”
Ford himself laid it all out in black and
white:
The harder we crowd business for time, the
more efficient it becomes.
The more well-paid leisure workmen get, the
greater become their wants.
These wants soon become needs.
Well-managed business pays high wages and
sells at low prices.
Its workmen have the leisure to enjoy life
and the wherewithal with which to finance
that enjoyment.
In the early 19th century in Britain, a series
of “Factories Acts” were passed meant
to help improve working conditions for workers,
particularly for children.
One of the first of these was in 1802 and
stipulated children under the age of 9 were
not to be allowed to work and, rather, must
attend school.
Further, children from the ages of 9-13 were
only allowed to work eight hours per day and
children from 14-18 could only work a maximum
of 12 hours per day.
Unfortunately, this law was largely ignored
and almost never enforced in any way.
Further, even when it rarely was enforced,
the fines were small enough that it was more
profitable for factory owners to break this
law and pay the fine, than to follow it.
The act also did nothing for adults except
require that factories be well ventilated,
though it did not stipulate what defines “well
ventilated”, so factory owners could easily
ignore this part of the act as well.